from the garden of eden to the top
corner of your english teacher's desk
apples have played an equal role in
history's most remarkable days and also
its most mundane the sounds of teeth
snapping through the skin sinking into
flesh and spitting out seeds echo
through space forever and onward and for
most of our earthly hours consumed by
appetite it has been documented to be a
lopsided relationship between these two
things man and apple man getting the
sweet taste and abundant nutrients
apples getting nothing but pain and
stomach acids but this story is not
found in our history buried in the
lawful patterns of predator and prey we
stumble upon an irregularity an
inversion an instance of apples biting
back
scp-4608 also known as appleseed was a
60-acre apple orchard containing over 22
000 trees located just on the outskirts
of milan indiana a town so small it
strains your eyes as you squint to find
it with a microscope hovering just over
a map and to see what was actually
happening within the curious fringes of
society took even greater exploration
not just of the eyes but also of the
mind because what would eventually be
seen would not so easily be comprehended
physical senses are just the surface and
we need to go deeper our story begins
with a great logging company looking to
take ownership of the most fertile land
they could find in the great lakes
region ideally land that overproduces
conifer growth so that the return on
their investment would be plentiful and
perpetual these lumberjacked men knew
what they wanted beneath their red
flannel shirts and muddy boots was a
deep intelligence and understanding of
nature their process of assessing the
land's value was meticulously calculated
they knew the soil both by the
experience of their calloused hands and
the literature of their study they
tracked various bird species migration
patterns in the area to assess what kind
of seeds they'd be carrying and
contributing to soil by way of their
stool they understood the local laws
relating to clear cutting and
conservation and how both would affect
their profit margins this is all to say
it wasn't just a speculative purchase
this was planned through and through and
dwelled on and yet even then with
scrupulous eyes and careful crew they
missed the warning signs
scp-4608 checked all their boxes and
then some what could go wrong and so
they acquired the land unwittingly
purchasing the peril that came with it
on the first day of owning the property
one crew member noticed the branches did
not sway in the same direction as the
wind blew he noticed the leaves didn't
float down in agreement with their
feathery weight but rather crashed to
the soil like two dimensional anvils and
grand pianos the roots were not ones you
simply trip over instead it seemed as if
they stuck their leg out to trip you
when birds perched themselves up high
and sang their songs their cadence
carried all the eeriness of an sos with
all this said he was happy to have
acquired the land and having already
picked up and moved his family from the
west coast to now live and work out in
milan indiana he decided it was best to
look past his concerns after all it was
the first day on the new site and
excitement was in the air but with it
also an amorphous anxious energy during
the first logging expedition within
scp-4608
this same member of the crew hiked the
grounds to better familiarize himself
with the environment he'd be working on
hoping that if he managed the land
properly and extracted the lumber as
efficiently as his late father did he
would be able to help build the business
and give his children the life he always
promised them he brought with him his
notepad and took detailed records of his
surroundings he figured to achieve his
goals and sustained long-term yields
he'd have to cooperate with his
environment but he never questioned if
his environment wanted to cooperate with
him would this question have changed the
course of action or is brooding on the
preference of plants an empty gesture
best left for hippies at woodstock
either way the orchard let it be known
how it felt about a collaboration when
hours later the man was found dead it
was first believed by his co-workers to
be a result of a safety equipment
malfunction maybe it was a simple matter
of thinking the skitter was in park when
it was really in neutral maybe the
knuckle boom loader went on the fritz
how it does when the humidity ramps up
maybe machinery really was to blame in
which case you call it a fluke and ask
no more after all there's only so many
questions you can ask a robot but
initial belief is a fickle thing and it
wasn't long until first impressions were
called into question by the courts of
critical thinking the questions of the
crew however only rang briefly because
shortly after the first death fell a
sequence of others in a matter of days
all the remaining crew members were
declared dead or missing a word reserved
for search parties still clinging to
hope a hot potato they would have been
wise to abandon for while it was hope
that brought these search parties
together it was hope that sent them off
never to be seen again the foundation
was then alerted to the occurrences
surrounding
scp-4608 by police reports accompanied
by a photograph a photograph of an
scp-4608-1
an organism consisting of unidentified
plant-like muscular structures and a
periderm resembling those found on
common hardwoods from the photograph
alone it was clear that this three meter
tall organism was capable of committing
the violence recently endured forceful
in its demeanor aggressive in its
presence and territorial in its
perception the photograph of
scp-4608-1 led to an even bigger
question is this plant-like creature
grown by nature or sown by man after
extensive research by the foundation
records were retrieved that indicate the
entirety of the 60-acre land was sewn
into life by john chapman in 1826.
chapman was the type of man you could
mistake for a scarecrow both for reasons
of preferred garb and body language he
was treated as such too his personal
space was respected maybe too much he
spent his life alone only accompanied
and comforted by the things he planted
he maintained these acres all by himself
until his eventual death in 1845
and it's then that it's believed
scp-4608 became unstable reassigning its
objective from comfort to chaos when the
newspaper came out the next sunday john
chapman's obituary painted him as a
priest of the allen county church but
was this just the art of illusion for as
far as we know no records of a chapel or
congregation exist a quiet choir indeed
come to think of it it seems that
everything within this 60-acre orchard
was destined to be silenced one way or
another by violent force or even by
conscious decision-making see while the
scp foundation has had a long track
record of subduing anomalies by methods
of capture and containment not all
things are suited for locks and chains
scp-4608 is better covered with a story
than a tarp a fruitless field that once
produced at an unmanageable pace is now
rendered incapable of supporting growth
most will think it's due to a toxic
spill in truth the spill wasn't that of
chemicals on soil but rather corpses on
crops a week after receiving the
photograph of 4608-1
site site-81 sent a three-man
investigation team into milan their
adventure was equally abrupt a story
with no reportable beginning or middle
but simply a predictable end after four
days of no communication the foundation
presumed the three agents no different
than their steak dinner dead meat and
only then after the foundation's failure
to solve the case was it understood that
what we were to be looking for wasn't
people at all but rather answers to more
nebulous questions what's really
happening here and why is this happening
following the loss of communication with
the investigation team site 81
dispatched a high risk response team
mobile strike force bravo 7 aka hometown
heroes these men had all the makings of
heroes and they were determined to prove
themselves worthy of the title while the
alpha squad moved north towards the
incident site beta squad headed east and
gamma squad hurried west the crews
covering all directions of the compass
but south a coincidentally symbolic
gesture as if to say we will not be
taken down the mission was simple in
theory find out what happened to the
previous team and why but alas missions
never are as easy as their objective
statement reads in practice some might
even call them impossible as alpha
neared the incident site they noticed
the shadows on the ground beneath them
did not resemble the shape of the leaves
in the canopy above they heard small
drops of liquid tap tap tap on their
helmets yet it wasn't raining was it
alpha one ran his finger across the top
of his helmet and then examined the
residue left on his skin it was raining
just not water oh god upon looking up he
witnessed the reasons for both
irregularities bodies hung from branches
by their intestines casting shadow
puppets with their lifeless limbs blood
dripped down like a leaky faucet what
did this but before he could even ponder
the answer he heard a loud shriek from
his radio so loud that the radio itself
vibrated shaking its way loose from his
hand and falling to the dirt he bent
down and picked it up and this time
gripped tighter as if to tell whoever
was responsible for that noise that they
will not get away that easily he and his
crew followed this sound like a game of
marco polo blind to what may be ahead
they extended their guns and pointed
them into the distant tree line like
zombie arms reaching outward in the pool
towards the resonance of polo a small
comfort in a giant game of distress as
they press forward alpha squad proceeded
past all signs that pointed them back
stepping over dead bodies like puddles
on a rainy day soon they found
themselves crouching down next to human
remains attending brief and hurried
funerals for all their closest comrades
torn between staying to pay respect and
marching along to earn it the chest
cavities of the fallen had been ripped
open and filled with apples a grim
foresight into what they were up against
but nothing they could have ever
imagined would prepare them for what
they were about to see and they wouldn't
have to wait long another loud shriek
from alpha one's radio it shot free from
his grip and landed again in the dirt
the squad tried to ignore the
metaphorical implications of this
reoccurrence quickly picking up the
radio and shrugging it off as if the
five-second rule applied equally to
communication systems as candy bars they
pressed forward maybe out of bravery
maybe out of shame of going back and
while moving through the trees they
began to notice something alarming
etched on their bark what was it there
were unnaturally deep grooves on the
base of almost every one of the trees
but what exactly were they from
scratches from an animal or beast
infection decay their eyes drew closer
but proximity brought them no clarity
these sigils and symbols could be dated
back to a cult norse religion but in
that moment they were incomprehensible
to the men yet the message even if
misinterpreted was very clear beware
another shrieking cry over the radio the
bullets the bullets aren't they're not
working they can't they can't penetrate
the bark the grass is no greener over on
the east side of the orchard where beta
squad gets lunged at by an scp-4608-1
their defenses are futile but they fight
nonetheless sending rounds to the
attacker's chest leading to
nothing if
scp-4608 had a health meter it wouldn't
have budged in the slightest
understanding the negligible impact of
their efforts and assessing their
injuries beta squad scurries to retreat
to an abandoned chapel taking a brief
refuge from war only later to be named
quickly they barricade the door in the
chapel beta 9 tends to beta 6's wounds
who is in the worst shape of them all
cut bloody and beaten as he lays their
grimacing he shines his flashlight up
and down the chapel's walls until he
finds a reason to stop and holds it
steady illuminated is an assortment of
human skulls and if this wasn't dramatic
enough he then spotted apple seeds
embedded in beta-6's wounds apple seeds
that were starting to sprout beta-9 gave
up to him straight this is gonna hurt he
drew his knife from his belt and lowered
it into his comrades wounds beta9 dug
into flesh and bone picking the seeds
out one by one beta six his scream shook
the chapel's stained glass windows as
beta 1 stood guard he saw a blur rip
past him as if life had suddenly been
turned up to three times speed he spun
around in a circle to try and keep his
eyes on it but as his vision refocused
he saw beta 9 was now dead he then
shifted his gaze to beta 6 who was
looking less and less human by the
second branches began sprouting out of
his body like an all-consuming magic
beanstalk out of his chest out of his
eyes out of his mouth and when there
were no more orifices to exit his body
exploded making way for the new form
that had overtaken him the barrage of
branches broke through the windows only
two of them were lucky to be on the
outskirts of inertia outside gamma one
was on his knees thanking his dead
comrade for the grenade he stole from
his back pocket i could always count on
you to have my back even in death one
hand holding a grenade and the other on
his radio gamma one called off alpha
seven alpha seven request for backup
rescinded go grab a burger i'll take it
from here gamma one slowly glanced up
and locked dies with scp-4608-2
a large apple tree with 13 human faces
embedded into it a perennial plant with
great powers a gymnosperm that had found
a voice blood poured from
scp-4608-2 empty eye sockets gamma one
smirks get some eye drops shikko he
crawled over to the beast the faces
began yelling at him in indescribable
tongues let me refer you to a speech
therapist he jokes as he pulls the pin
of the grenade and throws it towards the
largest of the 13 mouths
scp-4608-2 chokes on the grenade forcing
it to inhale deeply the strength of its
lungs pulling gamma 1 toward it and
sucking him in the grenade goes off
scp-460
explodes the surrounding trees scream
and combust the orchard goes up in
flames the bodies of the fallen are
given an appropriate cremation gamma
one's radio lays face up in the dirt the
voice rattles it awake it's alpha seven
gamma one gamma one are you there can
you hear me please please it's alpha
seven please gamma one on october 16
1947 gamma one was recovered by the
allen county fire department unconscious
and suffering from exhaustion and smoke
inhalation the site 81 concealment team
took control of the situation and
quarantined the area using the cover
story of a toxic chemical hazard the
members of mtf bravo 7 were postuniously
awarded the foundation star for their
efforts during the neutralization of
scp-4608 and so the one question that
remains is how how did
scp-4608-1 become so dangerous and how
did its danger slip by for so many years
is its volatility by nature design or
consequence could it be that the
foundation failed to understand the
complexity of this creation during
chapman's lifetime there were no
accidents or fatalities coming from
scp-46
yet there is no reason to believe that
scp-4608-1 wasn't always capable of harm
maybe it always was capable of mass
murders but simply had no reason to kill
what if the logging company never
stepped foot on that land never brought
out their sharp blades and heavy
machinery what if this perilous orchard
was in fact docile but provoked what if
the proverbial tree only falls in the
woods when we force our philosophy on it
though
scp-4608-2 spoke in unidentifiable
sounds the noises were always recognized
and recorded as language it spoke with
intent even if misunderstood what it
screamed is still unclear were they
pleased for help or messages of hate and
would one even be worse than the other
john chapman might argue when facing
heavy machinery and trained artillery
would raising your voice even be a moral
decision at all is fight or flight
imbued not just in blood but also embark
now go check out
scp-1472 multiverse strip club and
scp-4840 the flying city of
audadopadopoulos for more thoroughly
cursed anomalous locations